you know ever since we started hearing
about the labor shortage situation here
in the u.s there's been so much blame to
go around some people like to blame lazy
millennials other people like to blame
the joe biden administration other
people like to blame poor people who are
just unwilling to go get a job and you
know there's been this idea that because
of the boosted unemployment benefits
that meant that many people were just
one willing to get a job they wanted to
just stay home and live off of
government resources the same was said
about the stimulus checks with the idea
that okay well if you get a thousand
dollars here and there you don't really
need to work which is kind of silly
really because obviously a thousand
bucks or 1200 bucks fourteen hundred
dollars that's not going to be enough to
cover your long-term basic needs and
indeed the labor shortage does persist
the number of job openings was at an
all-time high as of october at more than
11 million openings and companies are
struggling still to hire enough workers
to meet the demand but the truth is that
the labor shortage is caused by a
multitude of factors and chief among
them have to do with baby boomers
retiring early and a reduction in worker
visas that have been granted over the
course of the pandemic overall i was
able to come up with eight reasons in
total for the labor shortage situation
so i wanted to run through them all with
you here so number one and these are in
no particular order people are retiring
early estimates suggest that the us has
about two million more retirees right
now than we otherwise would have
expected if we had not had the pandemic
and this makes sense because let's say
you were 62 years old when the pandemic
started and you planned on retiring at
age 65 well by now you're about 63 and a
half going on 64. do you really want to
go back to work for another year or so
especially when you already are
semi-retired as it is probably not
especially given the fact that the stock
market has boomed over the past couple
of years so people's retirement accounts
are higher than they expected them to be
also real estate values have gone up
significantly so people assuming they
own their house and assuming they have a
401k or an ira uh they've seen a
sizeable growth in their wealth over the
past couple of years making it so they
may not have to keep working they might
as well just retire early number two has
to do with immigration the u.s
government has issued about 1.2 million
fewer visas to adult immigrants refugees
and temporary foreign workers and i
think this is intuitive given that
restrictions on travel were in existence
especially during the early phase of the
pandemic many of these restrictions
still exist today there's a chance also
that uh you know things can turn around
because now the department of homeland
security has announced that the biden
administration is going to be adding 20
000 new slots to a seasonal guest worker
program for the winter season but it
makes sense that given there's a
pandemic raging throughout the world
people just don't want to be traveling
from country to country number three
there's a skills mismatch 48 of workers
said that they were frustrated with the
search and 46 said that they can only
find low paying rules just because a job
is available that doesn't mean that
people necessarily want to take that job
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's a
good paying job and we know that some
people were able to take advantage of
their time off during the pandemic and
many people learned new skills they did
online classes etc and so their market
value has improved but if they don't
find a job that matches their skill
improvement maybe they're just going to
decide to hold out
number four commuting uh people many
times just don't want to go back to
commuting obviously during the beginning
phase of the pandemic many workers moved
out of the areas that would be hiring by
now like they moved from cities to rural
areas and they just have decided they
don't want to commute anymore that's
been my experience like i like working
from home it wouldn't be a total deal
breaker for me if i had to start going
back into an office every day but i'd
prefer to just keep working from home
obviously commuting can be very very
stressful especially if you have a long
commute like if you're driving an hour
to and from work every day i mean that's
just crazy and if you don't have to do
it anymore why would you want to so
commuting obviously is a big factor
number five child care
most schools are open at this point but
there can be cancellations based on
coveted cases at the drop of a hat maybe
the school year gets halted early
obviously we're seeing some closures now
with omicron
so sometimes parents who may be working
part-time while the kids are at school
they can't do that anymore because they
have to be home to take care of the
child or at least they have to keep that
as an option in case school does get
shut down number six is protests over
vaccine mandates there are some people
who are just not going to get the
vaccine no matter what it doesn't matter
if you offer them a carrot or a stick
and so obviously if they refuse to get
the vaccine there are so many jobs that
they're no longer eligible for they
can't work for a government agency or
they can't be a government contractor
they can't work for a company with
more than 50 employees they can't work
in certain cities in the country so
obviously that lowers their
possibilities when it comes to the job
market and that's also contributing in
part to the labor shortage number seven
fear of the virus cases are obviously
surging out of control right now the
omicron variant is super contagious and
so there are people who are maybe older
or immuno suppressed and they feel as
though you know i want to get a job but
i don't want to put my life at risk by
doing so and number eight the great
resignation this is a term coined by
organizational psychologist anthony
klotz who theorizes that people
especially pre-pandemic they would tie
in their identity with their work and
now with people taking some time off and
really being confronted with their
mortality because the amount of people
who have died over the past couple of
years it's caused a shift in their
perspective and they no longer wrap up
their identity with what they do as a
job and i think that you know maybe the
great resignation talking point is a
little bit overblown because after all
people need to work to survive most
people do anyway
but you know there could be some people
who decide i'm not going to work 40 to
50 hours a week anymore i'm going to
work part time or maybe i'll take a few
more years off and resume working later
maybe i want to
decide that i'm going to do something
else with my life so it's definitely a
mix of factors some of these things
you're going to be able to improve over
time other things you may not be able to
like for example the baby boomers
retiring early are you really going to
be able to bring them back into the job
market probably not they're probably
retired and not going to be entering the
job force again at least not in mass but
then there's other factors that will
improve as the state of coronavirus in
this country improves as we finally see
cases go down we finally start to see
deaths go down whenever that may be the
economy will follow we've been saying
this for two years now that you have to
deal with the virus before you can deal
with the economy and we'll hope that
this all sort of sorts itself out but
that's the sort of update now having to
do with the labor shortage and many of
the reasons why it's happening